good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight elon musk bought twitter
yesterday with the promise to restore
free speech to america and a lot of
people were thrilled by that news to
them it felt like liberation finally
they can say what they think out loud
they can participate in the life of
their own country they can be full
citizens again that's how they felt
but at the same time a lot of other far
more powerful people were not thrilled
by this news they were highly upset that
twitter will be lifting its speech
restrictions
the aclu aclu warned that this was just
way too much free speech and the naacp
strongly agreed with that the washington
post concurred of course but it took a
different angle it is terrifying explain
jeff bezos's personal newspaper when
billionaires start buying media outlets
msnbc and cnn did not laugh at that
claim they amplified it and added some
it turns out that elon musk is a
hardcore white supremacist
who knew
technically elon musk is an
african-american but 2022 has been like
that you're always being surprised
so how do you make sense of all this
watching from home
here you have one news story but two
diametrically opposed interpretations of
the same story
so how do you determine who's right who
are the good guys and who are the
villains
we've been brooding about this all day
and we've devised a simple test to
answer that question
we're about to show you two images both
of them are famous you've seen both of
them before many times they're both from
the 1980s
here's the first one get a pen and paper
and record your reaction to it and
remember there are no right or wrong
answers
watch
overnight the wall went up and overnight
family members were cut off from each
other a city and a country divided
there was a scramble to get out people
jumping from buildings even as their
windows were being bricked up
over the years there were numerous
escape attempts via the checkpoints
through tunnels even in hot air balloons
three decades later communism began to
crumble across the soviet union the
cracks appeared and eventually the wall
came tumbling down
[Music]
so those last pictures as you know were
from berlin in the fall of 1989. ask
yourself what did you just see
did you witness the triumph of the
irrepressible human spirit over forces
of totalitarian control or
did you find yourself annoyed by the
senseless vandalism of government
infrastructure
who did you sympathize with as you
watched that video was it the protesters
breaking down that hated wall
or did you find yourself feeling for the
prison guards in the background are
going to have a lot more trouble keeping
track of people once this sensible
barrier is removed
be honest write down your answers
now we're on to the second image this
one is from beijing china same year a
few months earlier
so what do you see here
there's a man standing alone in front of
a tank is that man a hero risking his
life for human rights or
is he a whole again
impeding the pros progress of a
government vehicle
who do you sympathize with the man or
the tank
these may seem like easy questions but
that's only because those images are
more than 30 years old everyone today
supports the fall of the berlin wall and
the freedom fighters in tiananmen square
but back in 1989 it was a mixed bag
actually a lot of highly respected
people thought the berlin wall should
stay up that would include margaret
thatcher and the president of france and
a lot of others
now that may sound shocking to you but
really it's not so different from what
we're witnessing now now today we're
witnessing a lot of well-respected
people who are arguing with a straight
face that twitter one of our main
avenues for solving political
differences should remain censored
they're telling you again with a
straight face that you can't have a
democracy where everyone is allowed to
participate in the conversation no in
order to represent the public the public
must be forced to shut up
that's what they're saying
so whose side are you on the man or the
tank
keep in mind that if you chose the tank
you are by definition a stalinist we're
not judging but we thought you should
know that the good news is you've got a
lot of company here's msnbc
there's studies that have been shown
that this power can be used to tilt
elections if someone were to want to use
it that way to sign enough to just rig
law and policy you want to rig the
discourse you want to make sure you
control the terms if you own all of
twitter or facebook or what have you you
don't have to explain yourself you don't
even have to be transparent you could
secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates
all of its nominees or you could just
secretly turn down the reach of their
stuff and turn up the reach of something
else and the rest of us might not even
find out about it till after the
election
oh see if
if a billionaire controlled twitter you
could
rig the discourse that's a fair point
see the thing about owning a social
media company is you could quote
secretly ban one party's candidate
or even scarier than that you could
quote secretly turn down the reach of
their stuff or turn up the reach of
something else and the rest of us might
not find out about it until after the
election
yeah that's a terrifying prospect
democracy could not withstand that let's
hope it never happens
what is it about cable television that
completely eliminates people's
self-awareness maybe nih should do a
study on that it seems like a legitimate
health crisis
we're being slightly unfair in that
analysis we do not mean certainly to
suggest that it's only democrats who
favor censorship for political ends
republican leaders support it too
in a phone call reported today by the
new york times for example
congressman kevin mccarthy of california
told his close friend liz cheney that he
hoped the social media companies would
censor more conservative republicans in
congress
donald trump the sitting president had
already been silenced by those companies
but mccarthy wanted the tech oligarchs
to do more to force disobedient
lawmakers off the internet quote
quote
can't they take their twitter accounts
away too
those are the tape recorded words of
congressman kevin mccarthy a man who in
private turns out sounds like an msnbc
contributor
and yet unless conservatives get their
act together right away kevin mccarthy
or one of his highly liberal allies like
elise stefanik is very likely to be
speaker of the house in january that
would mean we will have a republican
congress led by a puppet of the
democratic party
so you wouldn't know any of this unless
it was leaked and you can start to see
why the people in charge oppose
transparency and fervently support
censorship on both sides why because the
more you know about them the less
satisfied you're likely to become with
their leadership
here's the eunuch general of cnn's
praetorian guard warning the peasants
cannot have too much liberty
if you get invited to something where
there are no rules where there is total
freedom forever everybody do you
actually want to go to that party or are
you gonna decide to stay home oh you're
going to stay home
[Laughter]
actually
if you let people choose you never know
what they're going to do for example cnn
just spent more than a quarter of a
billion dollars on a streaming service
that in the end attracted 10 000 viewers
right because people had a choice and
that's not what they chose
so if you're part of a company that made
a decision like that you'd be very much
in favor of squelching the competition
with censorship
because if you didn't have a monopoly
you would wither and die
people would start asking questions like
why is equity so important again
why do we care what tv personalities
look like shouldn't we care about what
they do what they believe about their
characters
over on the view host sonny haasen is
desperately hoping you will never be
allowed to ask that question
on twitter it is predominantly straight
white men so when elon musk says wow
this is about free speech it seems to me
that it's about free speech of straight
white men elon musk lives in a world in
which the only kind of free speech
is
white men
feeling free
to say whatever the hell they want
oh
now we could rebut those points and
these people are obviously racist and
nobody says anything about it for some
reason but that's not really the big
point the big point we're going to
restate it because it's the whole point
is this
anyone who is angered by the prospect of
american citizens expressing their
opinions
is a stalinist and should be feared
we no longer need to guess who those
people are they have conveniently
self-identified
it's a clarifying moment but it's also a
little scary because at this point there
is no going back
once the kidnapper shows you his face he
can't release you god knows what happens
next the body administration has jumped
with all four paws into this signaling
it's going to use the weight of the
federal government to crush elon musk
because he wants you to speak freely
the day that musk announced his
intention to buy twitter the feds opened
a probe into tesla that would be his
electric car company and the source of
the wealth that made it possible for him
to buy twitter and at the same time the
buy administration's allies in the media
are uniting to defame elon musk and
destroy him as a man because that's what
they do he's a racist
they're about to do that to us again
the new york times editorial board has
published a stirring defense of
censorship in a newspaper
on twitter the times complained musk
will be free to quote body shame people
he can also quote poo poo sound health
regulations and shout down critics
and that can't be allowed thou shall not
body shame tony fauci tony fauci is a
very tall man
by the way the vaccines work flawlessly
not very subtle cnbc was even less
subtle by the way in its character
assassinations that channel granted
anonymity to a source identified as
quote close to some of the democratic
party's biggest silicon valley mega
donors
what did this source come over to cnbc
to say quote
musk is a great engineer and businessman
but i would not trust him with my
daughter
oh so he's a rapist now i god it okay no
evidence whatsoever but you should be
afraid for your daughters because elon
musk wants free speech and nbc nightly
news in between prostate health segments
strongly agrees with that
watch them tell you that free speech
endangers women way more than abortion
clinics tic toc and teen vogue watch and
some critics are concerned that musk's
pursuit of free speech will collide with
growing safety problems on twitter
especially for women and minorities
do you trust elon musk to make twitter
better for women no i
i don't trust elon musk to make twitter
better for women at all
oh it's bad for women
it's pretty [ __ ]
oh the rich entitled ladies won't have a
voice okay
but of course everyone will have a voice
and that's what they're mad about what
they don't want is the coming of
diversity the one thing they say they
love there's no diversity of twitter as
it stands 99 of recent political
donations from twitter employees have
gone to democrats 99 80 98.7
to be precise
now
how much is that well for perspective
kim jong-un got a much smaller level of
support from workers at the central
pyongyang steel plant recently
so 99
of anything is a bad sign it's a
terrifying level of conformity it
suggests brain death
but brain death is what they're
demanding
and that tells you everything as elon
musk himself wrote today quote the
extreme antibody reaction from those who
fear free speech says it all and it
certainly does subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight